apple has just officially announced
their next event
happening on october 13th at 10 a.m
which is
one week from today so in this video
let's go through everything we should
expect to get announced
and some things that we probably
shouldn't expect anymore
due to some very recent leaks and using
some common sense as well
so let's get right into it first off
apple's event invitations
sometimes give a very subtle hint at
what to expect
and at first glance this high speed
invitation doesn't really seem to make
sense however
if you take a closer look you can tell
that the two outside rings
look exactly like the top of apple's
homepod smart speaker
and if you look at the inside it kind of
looks like a smaller homepod
except looking at it from an angle and
this actually makes a whole lot of sense
because a new homepod mini has been
rumored for months now
which will compete with amazon's more
budget-friendly echo speakers
now what makes this even more likely is
an article posted yesterday
by bloomberg's mark german a very
reliable apple leaker
apparently apple has stopped selling
rival earphones and smart speakers
ahead of their october 13th event
including headphones from bose
logitech and smart speakers from sonos
apple even went as far as to remove all
third-party audio devices from their
retail stores
telling bose that from now on and going
into the future
apple will only be selling apple and
beats
speakers this is huge news which hints
at apple releasing new audio products
next week including a potential home pod
2
and a new homepod mini at a more budget
friendly price
probably out of price range from 100 to
150
on top of that apple's new airpods
studio on-ear headphones
have been rumored for months as well and
john prosser even got his hands on them
and gave us 3d renders of what they'll
look like
saying that they're basically ready to
ship these headphones are incredibly
interesting because they'll be the first
set of headphones
that are fully reversible being able to
detect
the left and right ears automatically by
using apple's new u1 chip
and these will probably be expensive as
much as
350 dollars along with that john prosser
also showed off 3d renders of apple's
long rumored air tags
which basically utilize the new u1 chip
to give you
incredibly accurate device tracking air
tags are going to be small
probably around the size of a quarter or
a half dollar
allowing you to place them into any item
like your backpack
or even your wallet and you'll be able
to name them
and track them just like you would with
any apple device you currently own
so we should definitely expect apple to
announce those but we're not really sure
how much they're gonna cost
now what's interesting is that apple
released the apple watch series 6 last
month
which actually includes apple's new u1
ship
but apple didn't really mention the
benefits of the chip
and john prosser has said that every
single portable flagship apple device
going forward
will be coming with the u1 chip built in
and he mentioned that it's very
important to the future of apple
so we should definitely expect apple to
talk about that new u1 ship
at the event and about all of the new
benefits now before we get into the star
of the show
the iphone 12. i want to mention that
there are already quite a few things
that apple can talk about at this event
so it's already getting quite full i
know you guys are waiting for apple
silicon max
a brand new apple tv with the crazy a14x
chip meant for gaming
alongside a new gaming controller and a
very small chance of a new ipad pro
refresh
but to be completely honest i have a
feeling that apple isn't going to
announce any of those products until
next month because if you think about it
they will all
either be using the high performance
a14x chip
or they're gonna be based on that chip
in the case of the apple silicon mac
chips
so to me it wouldn't make sense to cram
the a14x
and apple silicon mac stuff into the
iphone event
especially since both the iphone and the
new max are gonna fight for your wallet
because people are so excited for them
so i personally think that we won't see
the new max until
next month but if by some chance it is
gonna happen next week
i'm gonna be extremely excited now with
that said the last thing we need to get
into before we talk about the new iphone
12 lineup
is the potential revival of the air
power charging mat
rumors have been floating around about
this for a while now
with potentially two new charging mats
the air power and the air power mini
while the mini can charge just one
device the larger mac
is going to be able to charge three
devices at the same time
and it's rumored to be priced at 250
dollars
which is incredibly expensive for a
wireless charger
and then the air power mini could be
priced anywhere from 100 to 150 dollars
and with that let's finally get into the
iphone 12 lineup there are four new
iphones that we should expect
this year coming from the iphone 12 mini
with a 5.4 inch display
the iphone 12 with a 6.1 inch display
the iphone 12 pro with the same 6.1 inch
display
and an iphone 12 pro max with a 6.7
inch display now the most important
standout feature of the new
iphones is the new design with squared
off edges
similar to how the ipad pro or the new
ipad air looks
all of them should be getting an oled
display this time around
with rumors pointing to the lower end
iphone 12 models
getting lower quality oled displays
probably with worse color quality
and lower brightness and those models
will probably be getting some new color
options as well
the pro models are rumored to be getting
a new midnight blue color
which will look like a dark navy blue
they should all be getting a notch with
face id
although the 12 mini is rumored to be
getting a slightly smaller notch
since the display is so small at 5.4
inches
they're all going to be sticking to a
lightning port instead of moving on to
usbc
and some leaks have shown that the new
iphones should be coming with a new
braided lightning to usb c cable but
without
a power adapter in the box just like
they're already doing
with the new apple watches and we
shouldn't expect earpods to go into the
box either
which will lead to more sales of the
airpods and the new airpods studio
perhaps the most exciting thing is that
these new iphones will be getting the
a14 bionic chip
which apple has already announced is
going into the ipad air 4
and apple hasn't released that yet
probably because they want the iphone to
ship
before the ipad air so it doesn't spoil
the performance of the a14
now if you saw my video from yesterday
where i showed off leaked benchmarks of
that chip
you'll know that the performance of the
iphone 12s is gonna be absolutely
insane so be sure to check that video
out after this video is over
now on the other hand some reports are
noting that there's a chance that the
iphone 12 mini
will be coming with a slightly scaled
down version of the a14
potentially the b14 which sounds pretty
weird for apple to do
but if you think about it the incredibly
small size is going to lead to lower
battery life
so maybe they want it to be more
efficient now along with that
every iphone this year is going to be
coming with 5g support but
only the pro models are going to be
getting the super fast
millimeter wave 5g on top of that the
pro model should feature a new
lidar scanner just like we already have
on the ipad pro
but a smaller version and this could
enable improved
portrait mode photos and some other new
features as well
we're also expecting the camera bump to
get larger featuring
larger lenses with larger sensors which
will greatly help
for low-light photos and video and it'll
probably enable
night mode for more camera modes as far
as the storage
the pro models are rumored to be coming
with 128 gigabytes
which is really nice but the lower end
models are rumored to be coming with
only
64 gigs at the base price which is why
the prices
could start as low as 649 dollars
which is really impressive for having 5g
now perhaps the most disappointing thing
about this year's iphones
is that the pro models are probably not
getting 120hz
promotion displays now that most of the
rumors
are pointing to that feature only coming
next year
so there you guys go that's everything
that we should expect next week at
apple's october 13th
event and if this video was helpful go
ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
and be sure to check out the a14 bionic
leaks
that video right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one